if you want to sort of just do a daily
video collection on someone constantly
lying and completely incapable of saying
the truth you just find a jen saki clip
she's the white house press secretary
she gets up there she lies about
absolutely everything i would say it's a
combination of intentional lying partly
it's what her job is press secretary
you're supposed to be deflecting all the
time and then it's that i also think
she's either slightly brain dead or
something's not right there because i
just don't know what could you have a
soul if you were just like lying
constantly like that so maybe she's just
not that bright i'm trying to give her
the benefit now
first off here she is on forcing vaccine
vaccine mandates on the states these
requirements are promulgated by federal
law
so when the president announced
his vaccine
mandates for businesses that of course
were waiting on osha regulations for as
a next step
that was pursuant to federal law and the
implementation of federal law because
it's an executive order so our intention
is to implement and continue to work to
implement these requirements across the
country including in the states where
there are attempts to oppose them
okay so she's intentionally conflating
issues there which is where her lie sits
so yes there is an executive order
saying that if you work for the federal
government or if you work as a
contractor for a federal government
meaning you know you sell
ice cream to the federal government that
you have to be vaccinated your employees
have to be vaccinated i'm obviously not
for any of that at any level but that
part of what she's saying is true where
she's confusing things is that the rest
of it basically are guidelines it's a
press release there is no law executive
order or otherwise that is demanding
that companies of a hundred plus people
force people to be vaccinated
must force people to be vaccinated
obviously she knows that she absolutely
knows that but she's purposely confusing
it right that's what she's purposely
doing and also implying that the states
don't have as much authority as they
actually do because the federal
government should reign supreme over
everything else she actually went
further into that right here going back
to texas um
what is the president's message to
businesses in texas you mentioned
several of them who are based there um
when it comes to what the federal
guidance is now and now with the state
executive order what would the president
say to those companies as they're
determining what they should be doing
right now for their vaccine mandates
well we know
that federal law
overrides state law i would note that uh
earlier when we put out our guidance on
the president's
announcement about mandates several
weeks ago he made clear it made clear
that again as i said earlier
requirements are promulgated pursuant to
federal law supersede any contrary state
or local law or ordinance
additionally nothing in this guidance
excuses non-compliance with any
applicable state law or municipal
ordinance we put out guidance several
weeks ago conveying that clearly but
fundamentally beyond the legal aspect
which is unquestionable in our view
the question for any business leader is
what do you want to do to save more
lives in your companies
okay so there's so many lies and
confusions in there first off she is
telling you the truth when she says this
thing about we put out guidance yes
guidance not a law but her implication
is oh we the federal government put out
guidance so you the states have to do
what we say no that's not true now it is
slightly true what she said that usually
when the states and the federal
government are in conflict with one
another usually the federal government
power overrides it not always by the way
if you want a very simple example of
this of what's happening in the states
right now versus federal power
you know in certain states right now
california one of them colorado
i think where else is marijuana legal
give me a couple states washington yeah
a couple other states um
actually if you go to new york city
right now when i went back a couple
weeks ago all the corners that i used to
walk by that would always smell like
urine they actually all smell like
marijuana now i'm not sure if that's
better or worse but in any event
federally marijuana is illegal but
states have made the decision to make it
illegal not illegal right they've made
it legal so in essence the states are
doing something and the feds know that
it's federally illegal but they're not
doing anything about it actually every
now and again i hate to tell you this
but that barack obama guy remember that
picture of him smoking a doobie from way
back when he used to use the fed every
now and again to close marijuana stores
here in los angeles okay so the point is
there is some tension between the
federal government and states government
but what she's saying there that
unquestionably
the federal government is uh is more
powerful and has to bow
that the states have to bow to the
federal government it's absolutely a lie
by the way we have something called the
constitution you guys remember the
constitution right and these bill bill
of rights they're quite fascinating and
they
illuminate certain rights that we have
to make sure that the government never
becomes too powerful i'd like to
sum up the 10th amendment to you and
really listen to this the powers not
delegated to the united states by the
constitution nor prohibited by it to the
states are reserved to the states
respectively or to the people
in other words federal law does not
always overpower state law if something
is not specifically delineated to the
federal law then the states are allowed
to make their own choices
this is where we'll end up probably in
court with a lot of these things but
there is nothing legally wrong with what
greg abbott did and if you're in texas
and you're upset about your governor
giving you too much freedom you should
move to california now ironically no
one's moving to california right we know
california had its first net loss of
population in 2020 in the first
for the first time in the history of the
state it'll probably happen for the
second time when we get the numbers on
2021. so she's lying there because she's
saying that basically a press release
and guidance overruns states and when
she says unquestionably it's like these
people are ripping the mask off and
really telling you who they are we have
all the power
it doesn't matter where you live we're
gonna make you do what we want you to do